Jason is with us in Bowling Green
hi Jason how are you I'm doing good how
are you doing Dave better than I deserve
how can I help sir well long story short
I'm 31 right now and an ex that I had
she had the I guess you'd say spending
like the Senate and Congress and she
helped get me in a lot of debt right now
I'm looking at about forty to fifty
thousand and depth mm-hmm and how long
have you been divorced well say we
wouldn't even married that's or that
makes it extra fun okay oh yeah it's got
your name on it yeah it's got my name on
it and then is it about ten and credit
cards
do they any of them have her name on
them no okay so it's 100% in your name
and you've got her off um she can't use
them anymore right she can't use
anything that she's screwed up yeah but
she just walked away and you got you
you're left holding a $40,000 bag yeah
pretty much
okay what kind of debt credit cards ten
thousand credit card she needed a power
so and I kind of agreed where's the car
it got repossessed oh okay
so ten thousand credit cards how much is
the repo bill in gram ten grands my
magic number that's what they're
changing you for is ten yep okay that's
the deficit what they sold it for was
ten grand less than what was owed that's
twenty of our 40 what's the other twenty
let's say I've got ten and student loans
for her no this is for me okay
alright this is the one I'm I got you
see you got a $40,000 minute okay what's
your other ten
some plump think of where by the peon is
either ten is just kind of a little bit
in medical bills here and there and I've
also got a four wheeler okay
so twenty of it's you and twenty of it
was her but you inherited it got it out
your household income right now it's
about 36 40 grand and I'm looking at
changing jobs okay I make them well yeah
because I Drive a truck and these
electronic logs have royally but I
hurting on me not you
okay cool alright well I always make
more money helps the equation the second
thing is manage the money that you've
got and get on every dollar calm
download the app it's free for your
laptop or your iPhone your Android and
it'll help you track your spending
because when you make your money behave
it works harder it's you'll feel like
you got to raise doing that alone but
you're right let's do some things to get
your income up part-time a hand
long-term as far as changing jobs
consisted completely obviously the four
wheeler is gone you got to sell it yeah
I've been trying to figure out what the
bay with that as far as selling it or
cut up all the credit cards and then
we're gonna list all of your debts
smallest to largest when you're doing
that for the car repo do not pay them
anything let it sit there but put twenty
five hundred dollars in for the car repo
in your debt snowball list because you
can settle the ten for twenty five
hundred when you get to it I suspect
some of these credit cards are smaller
than twenty five hundred so we're gonna
knock off some of the little stuff first
but when we get up to listing them
smallest to largest up to twenty-five
hundred then I want you to save up
twenty five hundred I want you to call
the repo people and offer them that as a
settlement in full get it in writing and
negotiate with them and now we just got
our forty thousand down to thirty two
thousand - a four wheeler
and so now we're down into the 20000
range or whatever that four-wheeler
brings 20 something thousand range and
then you begin to just work like a crazy
man and completely focus on this and
work your way through it
you can do it I appreciate you listening
you call me back you need some help as
you go along but that's exactly how I
would do this get really focused really
intentional this is the Dave Ramsey show